i was flabbergasted and frankly my first
thought was oh my god it was really
uncomfortable for my results to be
released publicly before
i even knew what was going on the views
anna navarro and sunny hostin are
reacting to their live on-air drama last
week when the co-hosts were abruptly
asked to leave their seats after what
they thought were positive covid 19
tests
sunny and anna both apparently tested
positive for covid no matter how hard we
try uh these things happen they probably
have a breakthrough case and they'll be
okay i'm sure because they're both
vaccinated up the wazoo fast forward to
monday's show and joy behar revealed
that sonny and anna actually don't have
covet after all i am thrilled to report
that sunny and anna's friday results
turned out to be false positives and
everyone is safe
both sunny and anna reacted to the drama
that unfolded on live tv first sunny
thanked fans for their outpouring of
love and support but then got emotional
explaining how it impacted her
personally my husband is a surgeon as
everyone knows and
he was in the operating room and had to
be pulled out of the operating room
because god forbid he's operating on
someone and he's
co-positive it was particularly
triggering because not too long ago i
delivered the eulogy at my
in-laws funeral
so you can imagine how i felt
thinking that i could possibly be
cobit positive and my family could
experience another loss
a loss that i don't think my husband
could handle
on a lighter note sunny gave anna props
for keeping her laughing through the
stress of the situation
and anna's sense of humor was on full
display the political strategist shared
that prior to receiving her false
positive she spent the day with vice
president kamala harris's sister niece
and brother-in-law and mind you anna's
incorrect covet test came moments before
harris herself was set to join the
panelists for an in-studio interview
i'm thinking i'm typhoid mary and i'm
going to wipe out the entire harris
family in one week but then the
conversation shifted to another
political figure donald trump jr who
took a shot at anna's weight on twitter
friday writing quote given the anna
navarro news i think it's time for a
national conversation about the dangers
of covet 19 and obesity anna wasted no
time clapping back on air reminding the
former first son that she pokes fun at
her weight every day and acknowledges
she has a weight issue and then shots
were fired baby if you want to have a
conversation about colvin and obesity
you could have had it last october when
your elderly obese father had it
okay so it is a legitimate conversation
to have and fortunately for you you've
got somebody in your family who you can
call and discuss it with because imagine
having a father whose butt is the size
of a studio apartment in new jersey
go get a man you got the gall
to pick on me the view is currently in
its 25th season earlier this month e.t
visited the set to celebrate the
milestone where the hosts reflected on
the accomplishment and what it's been
like being together again after working
from home during the pandemic
it's much more fun to have
fewer people i think because you can
talk more and
more people can see we can say more to
each other even it it became like i
gotta get a word in here now you know it
was i don't i don't love that but we've
learned how to do that now the opposite
of that was being alone in your house
which is what we were for the past two
years
and now as
would be like well what do you think and
then all of a sudden i have to give a
speech i didn't love that i didn't love
that i like the audience i like the
camaraderie i like the fun of it which
is what this is about now and this is
why the view is popular for this exact
reason
[Music]